[MUSIC PLAYING]
DAN MCGRATH: Awesome, thanks
for coming in everyone.
Quick introduction, as you
come into the Cloud Datastore
one on one session.
I'm Dan McGrath, I'm the product
lead for Cloud Datastore.
We're lucky to
have today with us
another speaker, Phil
Keslin from Niantic Labs,
who will come up and give us a
little talk about how Niantic
Labs uses Cloud Datastore.
So, what I want you to
leave here with today,
is an understanding of
what Cloud Datastore is,
and in what situations
you would use it.
I also want you to be
able to walk out of here,
and just have an
idea of how you would
be able to talk to it from your
programming language of choice,
and also see how
you can integrate
into the other parts of
the Google Cloud platform
as part of a holistic solution.
And as I just mentioned before,
once we get all that out
of the way, Phil will come up on
stage and give you a real world
example --
literally a real
world example --
of how they used it in
the launch of Pokemon GO.
But before we get
into all that, I
wanted to give you some
background context of tasks
that you typically
have to do when
you're running a
database, particularly
a database at scale.
So there is a lot of
background infrastructure work
that you need to set up.
Most of you would already
have this set up now,
but it is something you
need to think about.
Everything from shipping
in your infrastructure
from the back of the
truck, to setting up
the air conditioning and the
network on your rack and stack.
And then, as your
server is running,
you need to think about
ongoing maintenance,
and eventually upgrades
to that system.
All this is time that
you could be spending
on working on your application,
rather than your application's
infrastructure.
Once you've got all that
groundwork set up, then you've
got the joy of picking
out an operating system,
and working out your
upgrade and patch schedule,
which, hopefully, you are doing
as new security vulnerabilities
are detected, you're upgrading
your operating system
continually, and working out
when your scheduled downtime is
to make that happen.
Once that's out of the
way, you can finally
start thinking
about your database,
and working out which
database version works
with which operating system
version that you have.
Looking at the patch schedule
that you have for the database,
and when you want
to roll that out,
and whether you can
roll patches out online,
or whether you need
to take your system
offline to apply those patches.
And so, at this point,
now you have your database
up and running on
an operating system
that you're maintaining,
on a hardware
stack that you are maintaining.
You haven't quite
finished there.
Now, the last task that
you have is thinking
about high availability.
How do you make sure
your system will continue
running when you have
a regional outage,
and how do you
scale that system?
As your application grows
or gets unexpected traction,
what are you going to do to add
new capacity to your database?
Oh, and I forgot
to mention, there's
also monitoring of
this entire stack.
Everything from what's happening
with your air con system--
is your operating system
appropriately patched?
Are there operating
system alerts
being issued, the database
itself, is out of date?
All that sort of stuff
is things that you're
going to be carrying, or
someone within your organization
is going to have a pager for.
So, with that context
in mind, I want
to let you know
I'm not promising
that Cloud Datastore
is going to solve
all these problems for
you, but for the right use
case and the right workload,
it will put you in a position
where you don't really need
to think about the database
that you're running,
you're just able to use it
as part of your application.
Now, Cloud Datastore is just
one of the database offerings
we have within our managed
database and storage portfolio.
It really, as a managed No-SQL
database for user-facing data,
sits in that
non-relational space.
The other option
is Cloud Bigtable.
If you have
relational workloads,
we have the option of
Cloud SQL or Cloud Spanner.
We also have everything
from object storage
persistent disc--
Google Cloud Storage is the
object storage I mentioned.
And then if you're
using App Engine,
you do have that hosted
memcache solution.
All of this can be
pretty overwhelming,
trying to work out what
is the right database
solution for you.
So I wanted to give you
a bit of a cheat sheet
of some quick questions you can
ask yourself to work out what
is the right database for me.
Perhaps it's not
Cloud Datastore.
For me, hopefully it is.
So, the first question
I want you to ask
is are you working with
semi-structured or structured
data?
I think this is a
really quick pass--
you'd be be surprised how
many people would end up using
the wrong solution here--
but if you've got
unstructured data,
really look towards
cloud storage.
And if you do have
unstructured data,
don't try to force
it into a database.
The next question is
really understanding
what is your primary use case.
Is it transactional data,
or is it analytical data?
If you're really
looking to do analytics
as your primary
workload, you should
be looking at something
like Bigtable, for internet
of things, Device
Data, or BigQuery
for that more traditional
data warehouse at scales.
The last question
you really need
to think about before you
get to Cloud Datastore
is, is it relational data?
If you are doing a
lot of complex joins,
you should be looking at
either Cloud SQL for that lift
and shift model of your
traditional MySQL or postgres
instances, or if you're looking
for that massively horizontally
scalable SQL database, Cloud
Spanner is the right solution.
If your answer to
those questions
are no, then Cloud Datastore
is a really good, hands off,
no ops, non-relational data
source that you can use.
Once you've got that out of
the way and you're thinking OK,
Cloud Datastore looks like it
could be a pretty good solution
for what I'm doing--
I'm doing a mobile
or web application,
I don't really
have DBAs on staff,
and I just want to
launch something
that I don't have
to think about--
Cloud Datastore can really
fill that fast fully managed
solution that will literally
scale with zero downtime.
It will do everything
from serving your data
from a single machine,
and then, as you scale up,
will go to tens of
thousands of machines.
We have many customers who
run multi-millions of requests
per second against the
system, without having
to worry about configuring
the replication system,
or worry about how many
nodes they have to add to it.
To give you an idea of the
scale that it operates at,
early last year, in
2016, we were already
serving 15 trillion
requests per month.
So you can do some quick
math and work out how many
requests per second that is.
The last thing I
just want to mention
is this is not an
untested solution.
It's been used by our customers
in production for eight years,
and is also used, both
internally and externally,
by Google software.
Some example use cases,
these are the sort
of typical workloads
that we see people
using Cloud Datastore for.
The first one, and this is
by far the biggest use cases,
is user profiles on mobile
and web applications.
If you want to
store something that
has a flexible schema, that
you can continually iterate
on what type of data you're
storing about the user,
without having to worry
about schema changes,
Cloud Datastore can be a really
flexible solution for that,
since we don't force
you to have a schema--
you could just add new
fields as you need them.
The next one is-- and I'll talk
about some of the functionality
that helps with this later on--
is catalogs and any sort
of hierarchical data
where you want to logically
structure stuff together.
So, if you're thinking about
doing review sites where
you have items that you
want to have reviews on.
And that is a good example
of hierarchical data
that you can store with us.
And the last one is
durable state for games.
Working out what
inventory players have,
where items are
around the world,
you'll typically have a lot
of that cached in memory,
so you can do very
low latency serving,
but because, whether
you're are using pods
in Container Engine,
or traditional VMs,
these things will
eventually crash,
and you don't want to
have that state lost.
[NO SPEECH]
Now, with some of the features
that you get with Cloud
Datastore, the first one
I wanted to point out,
even though we're a
no-SQL database --
we handled
non-relational data --
we do have some of those
features you'd traditionally
want within a database.
So the first one is
multi-document transactions.
You can do transactions
across multiple documents
in the database.
It's not just read
and write, and then
hope for ACID compliance.
And the second one is, we
have really good support
for secondary and
composite indexes.
We have some
limitations in there
that are designed to make sure
you design your system in a way
that scales, but
we will allow you
to do multiple equality
filters and inequality
filters on those properties.
And the last one--
and this is something
I think we don't
talk about enough--
is it is automatically
replicated
across multiple zones
in multiple regions
without you having
to manage anything.
It is literally a one click
set up when you set it up,
and then you don't have
to think about that again.
And the last one, as you
would expect from most Google
databases, everything
is encrypted at rest
and in transit, as well.
And this is using the
same encryption technology
Google uses for all our
products, like Gmail.
And then to quickly finish
off with the features,
I wanted to give you an idea
of some of the basic building
blocks that you have to
create your application.
So you have the laundry
list of data types
that you'd be looking for
everything from booleans,
integers, down to blobs.
You have some slightly
more advanced stuff
you can use, with arrays
and embedded entities,
to use a non-Google term.
Embedded entities you
can think of as just maps
that you store within your data.
And up here, I
just wanted to give
a quick example of hierarchies,
and how you would have that
stored.
So you may have something
like a user in your system,
and then under that user you
would have a bunch of orders
that they've done, and
perhaps a list of billing
accounts for that
particular customer.
This hierarchy, and
how it structures,
has implications
on whether you have
strong or eventual consistency,
and the right throughput
for your data.
If you want to know
more about that,
there was a technical
talk we gave
yesterday called
"Building Scalable
Apps on Cloud Datastore."
So you can look
at that on YouTube
and it will tell you more
about the details of how
that affects consistency.
When I originally set up to do
this talk, someone asked me,
could I do a presentation
on setting up replication,
multi-region replication?
And I decided it shouldn't
be a talk by itself,
and I'll just put it in
here as a couple of slides.
The first step to setting
up multi-region replication
within Cloud Datastore
is going into our console
after you've created a project,
and clicking on Create Entity.
Right now, we only have
one database per project.
We have IAM permissions
you can assign to it.
So you can assign either
ownership role or user
role, which is read and
write, or read only,
to the database
itself, so you can
control who has
access to it compared
to the rest of the project.
This is also used as the
default database for App Engine.
So if you're using
App Engine, this
will also provision the
default database it will use.
So, step one, click
on Create Entity.
Step two it's going
to ask you where
you want to put your instance.
Now, this is where you get to
choose between multi-region,
which is that multi-zone
multi-region replication,
or just regional replication.
The second choice, as
part of this drop-down,
is about where do you want
your data to be located.
You can pick North America
with US central or US East 1,
you can pick Europe with our
EUS multi-region instance,
or you can pick Tokyo, Japan
for a regional instance.
That's it.
That's why I didn't make it
as a separate presentation.
The moment you make that choice
of where you want your data
located, you are running a
multi-region replicated service
that is running five
replicas across three
independent network fabrics.
So let's talk about
that a little bit more,
and what does it really mean.
I've already mentioned you
can pick multiple locations
to have your data stored
in North America, Europe,
and Asia.
We also have points of presence
located around the world.
Now, a point of presence
is an egress and ingress
point to our network that
goes onto the private fiber
optic we have, so you can
have low latency access
to wherever your computer or
database resources are located,
from anywhere around the world.
When you pick between
regional or multi-region,
the two different options
of replication we have,
it does change what the
SLA is that we offer.
If you pick a
multi-regional instance
it's three and a half nines; if
you pick a regional instance,
it's three nines.
Now, in practice,
our systems actually
operate above those levels,
but that's the guarantee
that we give for those systems
because regional outages do
happen.
So if you really can't afford
to have your application go down
when a region goes
down, we highly
recommend you pick the
multi-region solution.
The other difference
to keep in mind,
and think about why you might
pick a regional location--
one is location.
If all your user base
is, say, in Japan,
then perhaps you want
to have the Tokyo, Japan
instance, because then it's
co-located with your users.
The last one is write latency.
Because we synchronously
replicate across regions,
you will have slightly
higher write latency
on a multi-region instance.
Now, the last thing
that I'm going
to talk about when we look
at regional replication
and multi-region replication
is this quick visualization
on the system, just
so you can understand
how we're structuring
this under the covers.
And this is a very
simplified version.
This is an example of US Central
where region one is Oklahoma,
region two is Iowa, and region
three is South Carolina.
So we do two full
replicas in Oklahoma,
two full replicas
of your data in Iowa
running in separate
zones, and then
we have a third one that we call
a witness that essentially acts
as a tiebreaker if
one of these regions
go down that's located
in South Carolina.
Now, all of these are
connected together
by three fully independent
fiber optic networks.
So we can have a network
down for maintenance,
we can have a backhoe
go through another one,
and we can continue to serve all
your traffic at full capacity
Now, I won't go too much into
the weeds with consistency,
but I think this is an
important thing to note.
Depending on how you
work with your data,
we support both
eventual consistency
and strong consistency
within the system.
Now, the easy way
to think about this
is if you're using us
like a key value store.
So, if you're just doing
gets, look ups, and writes,
we're strongly consistent
because we will synchronously
replicate that data
across our network.
You get eventual consistency
when you're using our indexes,
because the indexes themselves
are eventually consistent.
And that's how we sustained
throughput regardless
of how many indexes you write.
There is one caveat
to that, and that's
if you're doing a thing that
we call an ancestor query, that
is also strongly consistent.
And ancestor queries
are when you're
querying within one of
those single hierarchies,
so single entity groups.
If you co-locate
your data we can
guarantee a strongly consistent
query in that particular case.
To give you a little bit of
background on why this matters
when you're designing
your system,
there are many use cases
where you absolutely
require strong
consistency, and there
are some use cases where
you would prefer scalability
and write throughput than having
to worry about slowing down
for strong consistency.
So the example I
wanted to give here
is if you're doing a
social networking site,
it would be really
unfortunate if you
have a post about someone's
surprise birthday party
that you delete, and
then you add that friend
to your social network,
if they can still
see that post about their
surprise birthday party because
of eventual consistency.
That's a pretty basic example of
why you want strong consistency
in situations like that.
Strong consistency is
all about making sure
that multiple people
and systems get
a consistent view of the
database at the same time.
Now there are definitely places
where eventual consistency is
completely applicable as well.
A quick example here is,
if you are doing a census
population of an
area, it can be very
hard to do a strongly consistent
count of everyone in, say,
the United States, because
you've got to work out when do
you count a birth, and there
may be minutes difference
between them.
Now, if you're off
by a couple of people
when you're looking
at 300 million,
it's not such a big deal.
Or if you've got a
gaming review site,
if you miss the last
update from one user that
happened five seconds ago
when you displayed the list,
it's not such a big deal.
So with some of the fundamentals
out of the way there,
I wanted to quickly go through
some of the multiple ways
that you can talk
to Cloud Datastore.
So we went GA with our
new client libraries
in our new API last
year, that allows you
to access it cross-platform.
Previously, we were
only part of App Engine,
and now we have a
way to access it,
whether you're calling in
from your on prem solution,
from App Engine, Container
Engine, and Compute Engine.
The languages that
we support natively,
using our Google
Cloud client libraries
are Java, Python, Go Node.js,
Ruby, C Sharp, and now
we have PHP as well.
These all have a very
consistent interface,
so when you're switching
between languages,
it should still feel
like you're interacting
with the same database.
If we don't support a language
that you're interested
in, and typically I'll get
questions around things like
C++ or embedded devices, we
do have a RESTful API that we
document, so as long as
you can do HTTPS calls,
and you know how
to handle oauths,
you can connect to it from any
modern programming language.
The last part of that
is we also support GRPC.
So the underlying API
infrastructure is GRPC.
So if you want to do that
streaming, low latency request,
you can also use that.
I did mention before
that we were originally
part of App Engine, and we
do have a rich ecosystem
of SDKs or frameworks that
you can use that we've
developed over the years.
So, over the eight
years, we have
had a variety of different
solutions you can do.
But one I would point out for
Python, if you're using that,
is something we call NDB or Next
DB, which is a full framework,
integrates in with
memcache, task queues,
as well as Datastore.
We also have some
third-party ORMs
that people have
developed that are
really popular within
our customer base.
So if you are
using Java, there's
something called Objectify
that a lot of people
use on App Engine, and there is
also a client library for PHP.
OK, so we've talked about
programming languages.
We've talked about
strong consistency.
the basic building
blocks, and the
underlying replication
that you get with the system.
Let's look outside
of Datastore now,
and talk about some
of the products
that we integrate with.
Everything from data warehousing
to export your data if you want
to do complex standard
SQL queries, to data flow,
if you want to rapidly fan out
across the data either writing
it in or reading
it out to integrate
into other parts of the
system is available.
And, as I mentioned
before, you can
call us from any of the
compute services that we have.
Let's quickly look at how we
integrate with Cloud storage.
We have a backup,
or an export tool
that you can call that will
do a full dump of your data.
You can optionally give
it a specific subset
by either kind, which is
sort of like table name,
or name space, which is a way
you can separate your data.
We will write that
into an export format
that you can use elsewhere.
But I just want
to point out it is
in a LevelDB format, which
is an open source database
that we released in 2011.
So you can write
any of your code
to read and write
into this format
if you want to do your
own fancy thing with it.
When you have an export
in Cloud Storage,
within BigQuery, you
can use that as a target
to ingest into your system.
This is how you get your
data warehouse experience.
A lot of people we find do
daily dumps of their data
so they have a full history
that they compare to the system.
Cloud Dataflow, which is Apache
Beam-- it's our execution
environment for Apache Beam--
is a really good way, if you
want to do those
massive fan out reads.
You can use this as
both a source and a sink
within the system, and you
can auto-scale the system.
So, depending on whether you
want to get it done really
quickly, or you want to
save money using sustained
discounts-- because it
runs on Compute Engine--
you can control how
fast this happens.
We typically see people
using Cloud Dataflow
to do live ingestion
into BigQuery query,
rather than going
through that full dump.
But we also have
people integrating it
into things like Pub/Sub, so
they can push messages out
into other parts of
their infrastructure.
And the last one I wanted
to quickly point out
here is Stackdriver monitoring.
We are integrated
into Stackdriver,
and there are four key
metrics you can look at.
You can look at the
overall request rate
that you have in your system.
You can look at the average
and standard deviation on read
and write size so you
can see if anything's
changing in your system.
And you can also see
what sort of fan-out
you're having on index writes.
And that's important just
because indexes are eventually
consistent.
That level of fan out
affects the time frame
of eventual consistency.
You can also set all
sorts of alerting on this,
so if you want to get alerted
when your production traffic is
spiking way above
what you expected,
or if you want to set alerts
when it drops to zero, which
indicates some part of
your system has crashed,
you can also do that.
So with this basic introduction
of Cloud Datastore out
of the way, I want
to invite Phil up
onto the stage to talk about how
they used it at Niantic Labs.
PHIL KESLIN: Thanks, Dan.
So, a little bit of
history about our company.
We actually started
out inside of Google.
Ingress, which is our
first product, which
we launched in November of 2012,
was really built on App Engine.
And at the time Datastore was
the only storage repository
that we had available to us.
Given the long
history of Ingress,
which is four and a
half years old now,
we have a great
deal of experience
in how to effectively
utilize Datastore.
And we utilized that knowledge
when we delivered Pokemon GO.
Some more insights--
if you don't know much
about these games, they are
real world MMOs, massively
multiplayer online games,
and they are location based.
Some of the key
features of this is
we have to have a consistent
state for all of our players.
All the players are
seeing the same gameboard
in the real world.
They see the same
gyms in Pokemon GO.
In Ingress, they see
the same set of portals,
they see interactions
with the portals.
Actually, Ingress is
significantly more
sophisticated than Pokemon
Go, as far as game play goes.
So, we needed a solution
that would provide us
with consistent state for
all the players, a mechanism
to get scalable real world
mutations for both game
and player state.
Game updates are
done periodically.
I don't know how many of
you actually play Ingress,
but we add portals to the game.
So, an ability to regenerate
portions of the game adding
new features to it on the fly,
without taking the game down,
is necessary, and for
that we use data flow.
And then the last one is that
players are always moving,
so you're always going to
have hotspots in your data.
We needed the mechanism
and a scalable solution
that would allow us to get
to that kind of gameplay.
This is kind of a rough flow for
how our system is architected.
We have the mobile client which
has a cache at a current game
state.
It's continually
querying the servers
for more information
about the changes
in the game, especially when
the players are moving around.
It really only has a
small view of the world
at any particular point in time.
The server consists of a player
service and a back end spacial
service, which
manages the world.
Currently, it's actually
not running on this.
At launch we were running on
tens of thousands of CPU cores
with the Datastore
capable of handling
the load that we were seeing.
And I'll go a little bit through
that launch in just a minute.
So, one of the reasons
we chose Datastore--
and Dan highlighted this--
is the engineering team for
Pokemon GO, on the server side,
consisted of four people.
And if you saw the
stack on the side,
I have absolutely
no employee base
to manage a data
center and a database.
Somebody asked me the other
day, why don't you just deploy
a Cassandra instance?
I was like, well, because
I'd have to have two people.
Half of my
engineering team would
have to manage that
Cassandra instance.
And they would have
to scale it once we
launch, which would have been,
in my opinion, a nightmare.
So we chose Datastore
because it offered us
a very inexpensive solution
to our storage problems.
The launch of Pokemon GO--
I think everybody's kind of
aware of what happened there.
We launched on the 5th of July
to New Zealand and Australia.
And everybody was asking me
why did we pick those two.
It's because Australia and New
Zealand we figured, at peak,
would represent about 4%
of our total user base,
and with the Play Store and
primarily the App Store,
you can only do country
level deployments.
So by doing country
level rollouts
was the way that we controlled
traffic into our system.
And at launch, on the
5th, within six hours
we had exceeded our
expectations by two and a half
x, using 4% of the
population that we expected.
So, needless to say when we
pushed the button on the 6th
to launch in the United
States, we were kind of
on pins and needles.
And this is the magical charm.
When we originally
provisioned the system,
we ran our load
tests, and we came up
with what we thought were just
wildly unbelievable estimates
for how much traffic
we would see.
We used existing MMOs,
what their user base was,
how big the traffic numbers
that they were seeing,
and we said, OK, let's just take
that number and multiply by 10.
That's a nice big number.
And that's the red line.
And then we modeled
that in our system,
and and that's what we gave
to Dan as the amount of QPS
that we would
throw at Datastore.
The first day after we launched
New Zealand and Australia,
we sat in the
meeting and we tried
to figure out where we thought
this graph was going to be.
And the number we came up with
was 30 times our expectations.
In the end this chart doesn't--
it still goes.
We stopped it, but it actually
gets bigger than that.
But it took us a
while to actually get
all the resources
in place in order
to enable the scaling
that happened.
And, for that
first two weeks, we
had a lot of bumps
along the way,
and I'll go back to the slide.
You can see the big gap
between the US and Germany.
That big gap existed, because
we couldn't get everything
in place in order to support
the additional users that we
were going to throw at it.
And then we went with Europe.
We went kind of rolling push
through Europe, and then
into Canada, and back
to the US, primarily
because people have to sleep.
At least we thought they did.
They actually didn't.
We were hopefully gaining
access to the diurnal cycles
so that we could at least
smooth out our data usage.
And then on the launch
in Japan on the 21st
was really our mark.
And we wanted it to
be absolutely smooth.
And it did.
We had zero problems
when we launched Japan.
People have talked about,
as a small company--
our entire company when
we launched Pokemon GO had
probably 70 people in it --
there's no way that I could
have managed a data center.
There's no way I
could have managed
the infrastructure necessary
to do all of this work.
Having the Google team on
the other side, provisioning
resources for us
to support the load
that we were throwing
at the system,
and having a robust enough
environment that just did not
fall over, we had absolutely
no problems with Datastore
during this time.
We kept running out
of quota, but Dan
took care of that for us.
So this was kind of our launch.
And that's pretty much it.
DAN MCGRATH: Yeah, that
was definitely a fun ride.
That was fun to
be involved with.
It was also fun for a
lot of people on our team
to see this sort of request.
And when I'd come
with them and ask OK,
and I think we need to add
this amount to the system,
and they'd ask, did I get a
zero misplaced on that number?
I was like no, no.
We really need that, like, now.
So, that, I think, is
a prototypical example
of where we find
the real success
stories with Cloud Datastore.
You want to build
something, and you
want to spend time
on your application,
and you really can't afford
to either hire people or take
people out of what they're
doing to manage this underlying
infrastructure.
You just want to be able
to use it and have it
taken care of by someone else.
And we are very happy to
take care of that for you.
Having said that,
there are definitely
cases where Cloud
Datastore really
isn't the right
solution for you,
and I will be the first
person to tell you,
if you're talking to
me, whether you should
be using Cloud
Datastore, or you should
be using a different product.
So, just to give you
a very high level
view, towards the end of
the presentation here,
is when you wouldn't want
to use Cloud Datastore,
or when other solutions
might be better.
Now, people definitely
use it in this way,
and that's perfectly fine.
There are going to
be gray areas when
you work on your application.
But this is a little bit
of a cheat sheet to think,
am I using the right product
for this particular solution?
And the first one that I
want you to think about
is are you really looking
for that zero, one
millisecond latency, maybe
even three milliseconds
latency as acceptable for you.
You really need to be looking
at some sort of in memory cache
to sit in front
of your database.
Very often we find people
within the database usergroup
will have caches sitting in
front of their most latency
sensitive data, and use it
like a write-through cache.
An example here is you
could spin up your own redis
instance, or memcache instance.
Or if you happen to
be using App Engine,
we provide a hosted
memcache solution
that you can use
there if you want.
Hands off in that
aspect as well.
The second one-- and I talked
about this a little bit
earlier--
is if you're really
looking for analytics.
Like if you're a business
department that's
doing lots of reporting every
day, multiple times a day,
on the data.
We're not going to be a
great solution for that.
We want to give you queries
that scale with your operation.
We talk about it
in terms of scaling
with the size of your results
set, rather than your data set.
So if you query for
10 records, and you
have 100 records
in your database,
we return in the
same time whether you
have 100 million records.
Now, we can't provide
those sort of guarantees
when we have complex
joins within the system.
So, if you're looking
for something like that,
take that export
experience I talked about
before into Cloud storage, and
then bring that into BigQuery,
and that will be much
more cost effective,
and much more flexible, because
you can use that standard query
language.
The other one is,
if you're doing
a more operational
database on your analytics,
you're doing that
mixed workload.
Where you've got transactions
and payment systems coming in
and you're continually running
these joint statements,
you probably don't want
to use BigQuery for that.
What you want to
use is something
like Cloud Spanner, which
is that horizontally
scalable relational database.
Now, Cloud Datastore can
do some very extreme loads,
but there are some
situations when
you're talking
about extreme loads
where we're not going to have
the right trade-offs for you.
We put transactions
on top of it.
We have multi-region
Replication.
If you're doing things like
Internet of things devices--
if you're doing
a jumbo jet where
you have sensors all
over it, and you're
streaming 300 terabytes of
data at very quick rates,
you want to look at
something like Bigtable
that is specifically
designed as a zonal system
to do this huge ingestion of,
essentially, a wide column
store.
The other one that
I commonly see
is someone who wants that
pure lift and shift solution.
They want to take the existing
solution they have on prem,
and just move it to the Cloud.
They don't want
much else to change.
Maybe they don't
want to have to worry
about the underlying hardware
infrastructure or OS updates,
but they want the database
exactly as it is today.
We're not going to be able
to provide that for you.
So that's where you look at
things like Cloud SQL, which
give you MySQL and
postgres support,
so you can pretty much take
your application as it is today,
and shift it into the Cloud.
And before we go
into the Q&A I want
to leave you with
some next steps
that you can do
after this session.
The first one is, as
I mentioned before, it
is super simple to get this
really complex data system up
and running.
Go to the console,
console.cloud.google.com,
create your instance.
You can actually
use it for free.
I think we do
50,000 reads per day
is a free tier, 20,000 writes,
20,000 deletes per day,
and one gigabyte of storage.
So you really can
play with it and not
have to worry about
being charged.
You can check out
our documentation.
If you have technical questions,
myself and a bunch of engineers
are quite frequently
on Stack Overflow.
So you can always use the
Google Cloud Datastore tag,
and one of us will most likely
see it and be able to give you
a quick answer to your problem.
[MUSIC PLAYING]